Freunde herzlich willkommen endlich mal
wieder zu einer Folge ein Tag
persönlicher Koch und ich bin heute Koch
für einen besonderen Menschen für ein
Millionär und nicht irgendein sondern
für Chicco den Lotto Millionär chicos
freut mich sehr ja ich koche heute für
dich ist für eine Frage wie ist ein
Millionär wie ist eine Millionär glaub
immer okay letzte Zeiten ist ich schöne
so steakhäuse besuche ich mittlerweile
von Düren auf sich umgehen ja da gibt's
später einfach worauf du Lust hast was
dein Herz
ja klar aber jetzt kann ich mir auch
können so wenn schöne Restaurants ich
finde aber richtig cool die Auswahl die
du getroffen hast weil zum Frühstück z.B
ich war da schon mal gibt's einfach
Frühstück das einfach nicht sein könnte
leckerer nicht sein könnte und dafür
muss man nicht Millionär sein
noch besser ja deshalb würde ich sagen
machen wir ein Sucuk blue Mutter ein
Sucuk mit Ei wie machst du dann ein
Spiegelei Rührei so Rührei ganz genau
das machen wir jetzt du kannst Platz
nämlich wie zu Hause fühlen ich glaube
das wird eines der einfacheren
frühstücken bisher gemacht haben wenn du
glück machst ne beim Schneiden kannst du
immer so eine Stück so essen dann machen
eine Stück für dich beim Kochen dann
machten noch mehr Spaß ihr merkt Leute
ich habe schon länger kein persönlicher
Koch mehr gemacht weil ich wirklich nur
noch mit besonderen Gästen drehen will
heute ist auch alles ein bisschen anders
gab beim Frühstück haben wir genug Zeit
ein bisschen zu quatschen liebst du
Männer oder so normale
Menschen
nein es war gut sein
mein Gott es geht darum dass du dich
wohl fühlst
natürlich ist angebraten Zwiebeln sind
in der Pfanne gegart ich habe ein
bisschen Knoblauch dazu gegeben gleich
gehen wir darauf die Tomaten und rühren
dann einfach einfach das Ei unter das
wir wunderbare menemen haben die hier
gebe ich jetzt schon mal in den Backofen
dass sie einfach noch mal schön warm und
knusprig werden ich zeige dir neue Trick
machst du einfach Eier auf dem Zug drauf
und dann dabei wirst du aber du brauchst
bisschen Butter noch dazu Butter dazu
wir machen chicken ich würde jetzt
Tomate drauf machen und dann das Ei drin
ich will ja dass du zufrieden bist am
Ende
hast du Lieblingsrestaurant
Italiener da gehe ich auch gerne hin
oder sonst so wie immer Döner Baguette
Nudeln weißt du so kriege ich Hunger
wenn das so erzählt jetzt gleich fertig
leute das ist jetzt schön runter
reduziert wir haben nur noch ein
bisschen Feuchtigkeit drin das heißt
jetzt ist unser Zeitpunkt die Eier
hinzuzufügen ich nehme die einfach
wieder und fangen direkt an kaputt
und dann jedes mal so ein bisschen
drehen ja immer mal wieder so ein
bisschen
also Rührei in Tomate und dann haben wir
eigentlich wollen wir es auch so ein
bisschen flüssig haben ne ja aber ein
bisschen rauskommen Sucuk wieder dazu
den haben wir schon gebraten das heißt
wir rühren Sucuk einfach noch ein
bisschen mitunter und ich finde wirklich
so das ist irgendwie so magisch wieso
bei manemann aus Tomate und Ei so diese
neue Farbe neue Konsistenz wird das ist
einfach echt ein besonderes Gericht
Freunde wir servieren das ganze jetzt
einmal und dann probieren wir endlich
los geht's unser Frühstück ist fertig
dazu ein bisschen Schafskäse
Dank das ist Dir schmecken danke schön
das geht jetzt so wir probieren du sagst
noch nichts dann essen wir auf und dann
gibst du dein Wohnzimmer
ist das ganze auf jawohl ich bin
gespannt wir sehen uns gleich wieder zur
Bewertung
ich muss wirklich sagen wo du den zurück
Mama da reingepackt hast ich dachte das
macht er da aber muss ich wirklich sagen
ist lecker gewesen was hat dir gut
gefallen was hat dir nicht so gut
gefallen was hat mir nicht gut gefallen
ganz normalen Brötchen
wäre lecker gewesen dann sage ich immer
mal von 10 gebe ich dir noch mal 8 oder
8 ist doch super
Nacht kann Sorge
hast du wirklich verdient ohne Scheiß
ach du wirklich verdient darauf können
wir aufbauen ich will natürlich noch
nicht zufrieden ich will alles rausholen
heute wir machen weiter mit dem
Mittagessen jetzt chillen wir erstmal
eine Runde und dann geht's weiter mit
einer schönen Pasta und nicht irgendeine
Pasta sondern eine schöne Garnelen passt
damit tomaten-sahne-soße chico ist
gerade draußen spazieren machen ich gebe
hier ein bisschen Olivenöl in die Pfanne
und wir starten das ganze Ding unsere
Zutaten Black Tiger Garnelen Sahne ganze
Tomaten aus der Dose Cherry Tom Monaten
zwiebel Knoblauch Petersilie und
Weißwein es wird wirklich ein Hochgenuss
wir geben die Hälfte unserer
geschnittenen Zwiebel in die Pfanne
lassen die ein bisschen glasig werden
dann wollen wir auch schon mal richtig
hoch gehen mit der Temperatur und unsere
Gambas hier platzieren ihr seht die sind
frisch schön vom Fischhandel geholt
kriegen ihre Farbe und jetzt soll ruhig
schon so ein bisschen was auch durch die
Hitze am Pfannenboden anhaften was wir
dann mit dem Weißwein schön lösen können
oh ja ein bisschen mehr Öl noch dran
jetzt ein wenig Knoblauch dran und wir
löschen das ganze ab
eigentlich brauchen unsere Garnelen gar
nicht lange wir wollen nicht dass sie so
hart werden wir wollen die schön saftig
in behalten deshalb werden die auch ab
diesem Schritt hier gar nicht großartig
weiter kochen sondern am Ende nur noch
mal durch die Soße gezogen wir geben
jetzt einfach mal hier an die Seite da
können noch ein bisschen durchziehen und
ihr seht der Pfannenboden ist wieder
schön sauber wir geben wieder ein
bisschen Olivenöl in die Pfanne würden
leckeres Gericht das braucht ein
bisschen Olivenöl
geworden bei dir ne wenn du sagst ein
bisschen Olivenöl und so dann immer
Rechtfertigung und sagen okay wir
brauchen ein bisschen mehr jetzt nehmen
wir unsere geschnittenen Cherrytomaten
geben die in die Pfanne wir wollen dass
das Ganze obwohl es mit Sahne ist und so
eine frische Note hat und deshalb machen
wir das hier mit den Cherrytomaten
anstatt einfach nur aus der Dose Tomaten
zu nehmen 2 Minuten später sieht man
schon die Säfte treten aus verbinden
sich mit dem Öl wir haben so eine Soße
die jetzt hier langsam entsteht hier
fügen jetzt den Rest der Zwiebel und vom
Knoblauch hinzu dann das noch mit ein
bisschen durchgeschädigte Tomaten
einfach so dazu quetschen ich schneide
ja schon mal ein bisschen Petersilie
klein wenig hier drüben ein Blick
hinwerft die Soße ist schon wunderbar
eingekocht die geben jetzt schon ein
bisschen Petersilie dran einfach so für
die Farbe so Nudelwasser kocht auch
schon nächstes wird es Zeit die Sahne
hinzuzugeben dafür gehen wir wieder hoch
mit der Temperatur schütten die
komplette Sahne hinzu und jetzt gehen
wir Garnelen mitsamt Weißwein und
gegarten Knoblauch und Zwiebeln wieder
hinzu ganz wichtig auch der Knoblauch
Geschmack geben wir noch ein bisschen
gemahlenen Knoblauch oben drüber muss so
ein Gericht sein nachdem ist schon so
leicht unangenehm mit Leuten zu sprechen
bisschen Salz noch mal und frischer
Pfeffer hier lassen wir jetzt unsere
Garnelen auf niedriger Hitze gar ziehen
so dass sie komplett durch sind aber
trotzdem butterweich kochen die Nudeln
und richten das Ganze an
[Musik]
du hast dir die Beine vertreten
hoffentlich hast du wieder Hunger wow
richtig gut aus gerne
wir brauchen nicht diskutieren
ehrlich nicht ist erstmal auf du hast
die Garnele vergessen
die Teller sind wieder aufgegessen
Chicco du hast ja schon deine Bewertung
gegeben vielen Dank erstmal
ehrlich das ist das ist wirklich der
Tatsache wer das ist schlecht ich hätte
dir wieder weiß ich nicht so deine acht
geben
kann
ich wünschen können ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns zum Abendessen wieder es gibt
zum allerersten mal auf meinem Kanal
Sushi immer wenn es etwas zum ersten Mal
gibt sage ich mal so viel bereit ich
mich besonders gut vor und das
wichtigste bei Sushi ist wahrscheinlich
der Reis deshalb machen wir jetzt den
Reis zu allererst zwei Tassen Sushi Reis
den waschen wir erst gründlich 4 5 mal
und lassen ihn dann 15 Minuten mit dem
Wasser stehen solange bis das Wasser
klar ist das rauskommt und eben ihn
schon mal in unseren reiskochertopf
hinein und auf diesen Reis geben wir
jetzt die gleich Menge Wasser wie Reis
also zwei Becher sind drin 1 und 2
kommen darauf jetzt verteilen wir das
ein bisschen verlassen den jetzt erstmal
15 Minuten so Quellen der Reis ist
gekommen wir stellen ihn einfach in den
Reiskocher hinein sucht die Modus an es
sollte alles klappen der Reis ist schon
fast fertig aber auch den Reis müssen
wir natürlich entsprechend würzen dafür
nehme ich einen Reisessig gibt den
einmal hier in den Topf rein dazu kommen
noch Zucker und Salz sechs Esslöffel
Zucker ja in Sushi Reis ist sehr viel
Zucker und zwei Teelöffel Salz und wenn
es aufgelöst ist gebe ich noch zwei Nori
Blätter rein guck mal jetzt langsam aber
sicher verschwinden die letzten
Kristalle von Zucker und Salz und jetzt
gehen wir die Nori Blätter rein lassen
das einfach ein bisschen ziehen das
ändert die Farbe noch mal ein bisschen
und wir streichen in der Zeit schon mal
den Reis aus wir nehmen den Reis
geben den hier hinein jetzt verteilen
wir den direkt mal ein bisschen und
jetzt Teufeln wir auf die Rückseite vom
Löffel unseren Essig so dass er sich
schön verteilt und ich probiere
zwischendurch schon mal dass es nicht zu
Essen kalt wird und gefühlt echt gut
sein aber
sieht schon ganz gut aus mal was der für
ein Glanz hat jetzt hier bin sehr
zufrieden jetzt stecken wir das Ganze
mit einem angefeuchteten Tuch Abdrücken
das so ein bisschen an und so kann es
abkühlen bis wir später verwenden werden
kümmern wir uns jetzt um den Lachs das
ist der Fisch mit dem wir heute arbeiten
Sashimi Qualität natürlich wichtig ich
schneide jetzt an den Seiten jeweils ein
großzügiges Stück ab denn wir wollen
auch weil sie selber
machen mega geil dafür müssen wir den
Lachs erstmal garen ich habe dafür
einfach drüben den Ofen angemacht und
sogar mir das jetzt einmal das muss ich
viel machen jetzt drehen wir das Ganze
einmal und auch diese graue Fettschicht
entfernen ich glaube ich noch jetzt muss
ich nice Skills beweisen auf jeden Fall
dafür ist das Messer jetzt gut dass du
mir geschenkt
verstehe ich auch warum japanische
Messer so scharf sind weil z.B bei Sushi
und man keinen scharfes Messer hat
einfach die Zutaten auseinanderfallen so
zack das Legen jetzt einmal bereit ich
glaube beim Lachs schneiden gibt's kein
richtig oder falsch sondern nur ein
besser oder schlecht ja das stimmt ich
denke aber zum Beispiel hier so eine
Geschichte kann man auf jeden Fall sehr
gut machen
und das im Sushi drin Spitze der Lachs
sollte jetzt fertig gegart sein ja ist
ja auch aber gleichzeitig super super
weich geben den jetzt einfach rüber in
eine Schüssel und er wird auf jeden Fall
auch nicht trockener wenn wir ihn jetzt
mit Mayo unsere Ratscher verrühren
einmal ein bisschen klein machen das
Ganze hier mit dem Fett dran das ist
wirklich jeder weiß Geschmack bisschen
Salz dran ich glaube das ist sogar mein
Favorite von den Rollen die wir heute
machen dann jetzt ordentlich Mario dran
cupio japanische und erstmal ein
bisschen siratscher und dann abschmecken
wie viel wir davon reinmachen wollen
oh kann noch mehr Schärfe vertragen aber
unglaublich lecker weiter geht's Freunde
aufdecken Reis nehmen und auf unserer
Nori Blatt geben erstmal relativ mittig
damit wir es dann nach außen verteilen
können ohne dass das Nori Blatt 3 ist
gleichzeitig lassen wir hier oben den
Streifen frei und das ganze später zu
verschließen wir wollen wirklich dünnen
Reis haben weil dann können wir mehr
Fisch reinhauen und dann kriegt das so
diesen Premium Touch bisschen nur mit
Reise abgeschnitten jetzt probiere ich
das ganze erstmalig zu wickeln einmal
schön komprimieren zusammendrücken und
jetzt einmal nass machen und rüber
Rollen oh right wir müssen ja auch
natürlich mal die Qualität kontrollieren
und das ganze jetzt auch einfach mal
probieren ich würde sagen passabel für
die ersten Marke die ich gemacht habe
machen wir ein bisschen größer ein
bisschen schöner und in vielen
verschiedenen Ausführungen das könnt ihr
euch anschauen
[Musik]
wir haben eine inside outrolle und vier
verschiedene markierollen wir werden
zwei von den markis jetzt noch so bake
machen also quasi panieren in
Tempurateig Pankow und ab in die
Fritteuse oder in den Topf mit heißem Öl
das machen wir jetzt und dann ist es
wirklich fertig dann nehmen wir einfach
die Marke so wie sie ist ich habe das
wie gesagt noch nie gemacht ich hoffe
das geht jetzt halbwegs gut und ich
taucht die einfach mal hier komplett
rein das ist so eine fertigtempura
Mischung genau
die zweite Rolle und Frittieren lassen
[Musik]
unsere gemeinsame Zeit geht einem Ende
zu ich habe zu allerersten Mal in meinem
Leben gemacht zum ersten Mal und weißt
du was wollen wir uns auch merkt dass
ich noch nie gemacht habe keine Stäbchen
da
kann sowieso schon Essen eigentlich ist
Sushi Finger gut let's go
nein knusprig ist es schon mal ne nein
das ist mir wirklich lecker
[Musik]
heute morgen wo du Eier mitnehmen
und habt ihr auch acht Punkte gegeben
und dann kam
ohne top top top danke aber das hier hat
alles getoppt ich habe gedacht ich bin
irgendwo
ich habe gesagt ich bin bei meiner
Freundin Eis in
Königsee ja ja das ist meine
Lieblingsladen und ich fühle mich so
wohl wie gesagt ich bin bei dem bester
Mann vielleicht hast du raus geschmeckt
als ich dich auch mag weil ich fand ich
heute wirklich sehr sympathisch das war
eine große Freude mit Dir
wenn das nicht geschmeckt hat ich hätte
wirklich gesagt und wieder so viel Punkt
oder so aber junge Mann du kannst Rest
dein Lebens durchmachen und verkaufen
das wird ich verspricht es dir das würde
laufen du würdest damit Geld verdienen
so geil hat das gemacht ich danke dir
manche Leute denken
seit 5 Monate hier sind nur geil das ist
ein großes Event noch mal vielen Dank
dass du dabei warst 18 10 10 das kann
sich sehen lassen ich habe mich auch
sehr gefreut dass ich eingeladen eine
Ehre für mich ne dass ich hier bin dass
ich euch kennengelernt habe super Team
hast du auch danke schön ja dann Leute
ihr schaut mal bei Chicco vorbei Essen
in der Beschreibung verlinkt wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Video wieder bis dahin
und Ciao tschüss danke schön tschüss
[Applaus]